People that initially when we used to show it,
they would just assume it was mercury. So cause it looks the same.
This sodium potassium found in liquid metal fountain is,
is a device that's enabled you to safely move these liquids around without
letting them get exposed to the atmosphere or to your skin or to anything else.
NAC is an alloy of sodium N a and
potassium. K.
And what makes it unusual is that when you mix these two metal,
you get a metal that is liquid at room temperature.
It looks like mercury, but it's very light.
In fact, it should float on water.
And it looks a little bit like mercury, unlike mercury,
of course it's highly reactive and you've got lots of videos that show reactions
of sodium potassium and the, you just don't want to, uh,
to have these kinds of things around the atmosphere around water.
You start dropping it.
It's so reactive will react with the water in the air and it'll be on fire
before it's even reaches the water.
It is a liquid and therefore the surface is clean.
So the oxygen and water in the air can get to the
surface much better than it could as a solid,
more than 35 years ago. There was a lot of research here on.
They used to use it as a coolant, so it's a liquid,
so it can be floated around quite easily, but it's a metal.
So it's got really excellent thermal conductivity.
So this liquid metal was a coolant and it was particularly used in the,
in the nuclear.
Neck was being used for cooling nuclear reactors,
particularly the sort of react to known as a fast breeder reactor and NEC was
chosen as the coolant, because as a metal, it conducts heat very well.
We'll take the heat away from a nuclear reactor.
Kayla here to wait in this liquid metal, deliver it to water without looking to,
to touch course. Uh,
and then the water will be turned into steam and that steam would go away and
would power turbine and create electricity.
And sodium and potassium can go in intense
radiation fields without becoming radioactive.
The problem is that it could be corrosive.
And so my colleagues were doing a whole series of studies on
corrosion,
which involved pumping round neck for days,
if not weeks over test pieces of metal to see if any of it
dissolved. That is the metal dissolved into the neck.
Because what that would mean is that if you use those metals and a
nuclear reactor, you could dissolve them away with the coolant.
And that would clearly not be a good situation.
Don't make your pipes out of that one. Yes.
The problem that they had was they needed to pump around this
liquid that was enormously corrosive or potentially corrosive
and reactive and to do so when it was quite a high temperature,
because they were simulating reactors that had the temperature of
two or 300 degrees centigrade, if not more.
And they devised a fantastic pump and built one
of these pumps out of glass so that it could be shown as a demonstration
for visitors.
Unfortunately about 10 years ago,
also before we started periodic videos,
it was decided that these demonstrations were so dangerous
that we had to get rid of them, but before it was destroyed,
my colleagues, Steve made the video about,
so let me explain how it works.
It is based on the same principle that is used for electric
motors.
You have a piece of metal carrying a current,
which is in a magnetic field and there is motion what we have
here. And this is a crude analogy.
We have a powerful magnet North and South magnetic poles. Okay.
And in between we have the container with the neck and then there are
two electrodes going in two wires that carried current.
There is a historic trick in physics for
memorizing called Fleming's left-hand rule.
So it's based on the thumb and these two fingers, which if you hold them,
write a rule at right angles.
And what this says is that if you have the magnetic field given by this
finger going in this direction from North to South and the
current going through in that direction,
you get motion going upwards in the direction, my thumb.
So what you see there is you see Steve cranking up the current as
he cranks up,
the current what's happens is that the liquid carrying the
current between the two wires experiences an upthrust.
And because it's very light, it's not too dense material.
It shoots upwards and you get to little fountain.
The pipe work is such that the liquid then just goes round and round
and round.
You can, you can see this on the video that you have.
The second thing is the current it's going to cost the electrodes. Uh,
the first thing is a field. That's the big magnet.
And when you put those two together and you turn up the, uh,
the current and you'll see me doing that in the video, then you get the motion.
And the motion is the fountain that gets flung up through that. Um, through the,
as a guest, as an orifice,
that 30 top the fountain goes up and then the stuff comes down and goes back
down the bottom and then gets thrown up again.
So you get this continuing cycle of liquid metal that's going around and around.
Because the stuff is so the whole operators is then surrounded by
glass bulb, which contains are gone.
So if there is a leak or being well, it doesn't burst into flames.
So the knack was going round and round and round washing the surface over and
over again.
And so you could measure the corrosion quite precisely.
And sometimes they measured the corrosion electrically.
They measuring the resistance of the piece of metal that they were studying
because knack is such a good conductor.
They could make the whole operators out of metal and it would still work.
The one we've got on the video is glass.
So you can see what's happening for the first 20 years that was here at
Nottingham. We used to demonstrate this to visiting students.
It would just be sitting in the corner of lab. And as we took a party round,
we'd say, look, I switched this and that. And they'd get all go, Ooh,
and perhaps come to Nottingham.
But most of them didn't realize quite what a historic piece of equipment it is.
My feeling is that probably it was an act of vandalism to destroy
this equipment.
And we should have just made it rather safer and still kept it because it is
really is Storic experiment.
As far as I know, I mean, I used to use this to demonstrate when it,
when it was, uh, not deemed to be, uh, too dangerous to do so, but then it was,
and it was taken away.
Of course we could fill it with mercury.
The problem is that mercury is very dense.
The mercury would feel exactly the same force from the
current and the magnetic field,
but it just wouldn't be enough to lift the mercury up because it's so dense.
What of course you could do is to put in a very, very much bigger current,
and then you could make mercury go round,
but probably something unpleasant would happen.
It would overheat or arc or whatever.
So it's really designed just for doing neck,
or you could use it at higher temperature for liquid sodium or liquid potassium.
Like everybody dealing with dangerous chemicals.
If you know how to handle them, they can be quite safe. In fact,
on the other side of this building,
there was a piece of operators that had two gallons
that is about eight or nine liters of liquid
sodium at a temperature above its melting point,
which is 96 degrees.
And you could go up there rather like to tear, turn,
and just take a thermos full of liquid sodium and take it
back to your lab.
And that was there for perhaps 10 years before they got rid of
it.
And so I never heard of any accidents at all from these.